the Lakeside setting may be stunning but
for kosovo's Border
Police there's little time these days to
admire the view kushim rashit served in
a rapid reaction force on this section
of the border with Serbia for almost a
year but he's never known circumstances
as serious as these we do food Patrol
lately because of the situation that is
between us and Serbian side that we have
a threat on from them it's a dangerous
area one of their fellow officers died
nearby in an attack last month when you
joined up for this job did you expect to
see these kinds of threats yeah in this
sport yeah comparing with uh the Serbian
side what is doing it's uh it's like an
offensive against the Kosovo
country kosovo's boundaries up here may
be difficult to defend but on regular
roads this border Serbia barely
recognizes is hard to miss this kind of
mobile Road check point is one of
several tools available to special units
inside the Kosovo border police forces
they say they've been intensifying these
kinds of efforts in recent days aware as
they are now that the threat from Serbia
just a few kilometers down the road is
more real than it has been in years this
police unit's usually searching for
smuggled
[Music]
Goods now they're more worried about
weapons that might one day be used
against
them it's difficult you see because of
the situation how is we are the first
line that who we face with these guys if
borders are disputed then it means that
there is no uh long-term peace in the
region Mentor roli is the executive
director of The Institute for security
studies think tank in the capital
Pristina as we saw last week p is not
safe if uh the borders are not strictly
controlled so I think that uh they need
to invest uh in the Border in order to
prevent the conflict from within for
rashi's unit us operating on its own
that mission is motivation enough we
will do our best we are decide to serve
to our country and our community we do
our job and we will insist to do that as
long as we are ready that means looking
to the future but also watching their
backs vill marks Al jazer burnac
Kosovo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer